Corsica from below this is where Stefan
legaia explores the seabed the
underwater photographer is always
looking for the perfect shot today he
shows us an amazing find 44 meters
beneath the surface lies the wreck of an
old ship we dive to the wreck of the
encima a German warship it was sunk off
Bastian on the 9th of September 1943 the
day Italy broke with Germany and the
Second World War the many wrecks that
lie off the coast of Corsica are the
Mediterranean island's best kept secret
only qualified scuba divers get the
chance to see them legaia wants his
photos to preserve these traces of
history
I stuck my head underwater and thought
we have to make these things visible to
those people who don't dive almost a
company about a foot - after our
excursion we take the boat back to
Bastia the harbor town is the economic
hub of the island it's well known for
its old quarter and for the Santos
Chapel one of the best ways to get
around the island is to take the narrow
gauge railway corsican is lovingly call
it Trina Galu or the shaking one this
lines been around for ages for
generations the trains still travel on
the same old tracks though the railway
is a bit like Corsica itself it has
tradition but it's also modern here
Tommy takes the train nearly every day
he works as a chemistry professor in
court a a small town in the mountain
range in the interior
okay has a long and important history
when the island became independent from
France under Pasquale polly Corte became
the capital today Corte remains a symbol
of the struggle for independence a
citadel tower is over the town which
boasts images of the independence
fighter Pasquale Paolo Li there are lots
of young Corsican seer the town is home
to the islands only University nearby is
the pride and joy of corsica's railway a
bridge built by the famous architect
Gustave Eiffel we're passing the bridge
over the Vecchio it's one of the most
beautiful things on the line
up in the mountains there's more
adventurous fun to be had
for the past 14 years Agni at a piane
has led groups of tourists down the
river verga aloo canyoning is a popular
sport in Corsica the goal is to get down
the river getting around objects either
by jumping climbing or up styling the
20k low railway head south from here out
of the mountains and toward Luxio but
this is the quickest way down
ludovic my Saab takes visitors
paragliding it's a flight they're not
likely to forget down the sheer mountain
slopes to the valley below
kima come in we have a really pleasant
climate with lots of good weather we're
protected from strong winds and that
makes a big difference
Corsica is one of the best places in the
world for paragliding our last stop is a
jean co it's the capital of Corsica and
the birthplace of Napoleon Bonaparte
Emperor of France from 1804 until 1814
64 thousand people live here but in
summer the city sitter is often deserted
as residents head to the sea some of the
best beaches are at Cabo defend oh the
classy Beach Bar the pirate is
especially popular logical news I tried
to retain the charm of beach huts you
sit with your feet in the sand you share
tables it's a place of freedom
the ancient Greeks called Corsica
Kalista or beautiful it's a name that
still best describes the island to this
day